从今天开始录一组编剧课。
一说编剧啊，很多人觉得有点距离感的，甚至觉得这个职业挺神秘的。
其实完全没有必要啊。
编剧呢就是一门手艺。
也是通过学习和训练掌握的一门技能。编剧教学这一块啊分两个流派。
一种是学院派。
学派就影视学院他们教的那一套教程。
呃，偏重基本功，偏重理论。你去看他们的教材，里面全是些专业名词，比如说什么。
吉利事件呀。
三布式结构啊、沟壑呀、灵魂、黑夜呀，全是这种词儿，让你一下觉得高山仰尺啊不可接近。
比较高深。嗯，还有一种呢是速成派。
速成派呢就比较街头了。
你一看标题，你就明白什么叫速成派啊，什么20天搞定电影剧本。
好莱坞顶级编剧的10个小秘密全是这种。
他是怎么教呢？他就是把一些商业片。
归纳总结，找出一些简单粗暴的规律性的东西，然后告诉你，这是普世的真理，让你去背，让你去按照那个去做。
呃，举个例子吧。
比如说前几年的。
韩剧偶像剧这一块，他们有一个第6级接吻法则。
啥意思呢？就男女主角在第6集要亲嘴。
当然是概念化的亲嘴啊，因为不能真亲，第6集就搞出爱情来，有点早了。对于一个爱情片来说，他们一般是怎么呢？就比如说。
这个男女主角困在一个狭小的空间了，困住了，然后就蹭上了，或者是女的摔跤了，不小心摔到这个男的。
或者是俩人喝醉了，哎，怎么着了？还有这女的在洗澡，男的不小心不知道闯进去了，然后就搞这一套。但是这套一搞你就明白了，这这俩人肯定要在一块了，对吧？就规律性的东西。还有呢比如说呃电影里面。
男2号一般要在65分钟左右。
资料。
男2号一死，哪一号开始雄起。
为什么呢？因为一般呃双男主的这种电影啊。
男二号会一般是男一号的分身，是他性格上的一部分，等于是他的一部分死掉了，导致他蜕变升华，绝地反击。
所以说这这就是简单规律。
这种教学我就说它是呃这个编剧里面的成功学。
他有什么好处呢？他给你信心，他一下让人觉得啊编剧我可以很简单嘛，对吧？但是千篇一律也不好，没有灵魂呀，偶尔也能蒙对啊偶尔也能蒙对。
这两种方法咱们如果把它看成。
学功夫。
假设你想学功夫这两种方法有什么利弊啊？学功夫学院派，那就是少林少林正统呀，对吧？你想学功夫，我得去上少林。
然后就去拜师。
啊到山上说，师傅，我想学功夫啊，师傅说，莫慌莫慌，你先挑水。
你想师傅挑水师傅说挑水，那咱就挑吧啊，天天挑的水那个上在山上奔挑了3年。
又去找师傅说师傅师傅，我的功夫对吧？怎么着？师傅说你去劈柴啊，咣咣咣在那劈，又劈了3年。
然后又去找师傅，师傅，我这功夫，你瞧瞧师傅说你去蘸梅花庄，然后又去蘸梅花庄，又站了3年。
三年下来忍不住了，三年又三年三年又三年，什么时候是个头儿啊，对吧？就去找师傅理论，说师傅，我来学功夫的，你看你给我整师傅说孽土口出狂言，然后就跟你你就跟师傅比划起来了，一比划发现哎哎。
我呀我好像会了会功夫了。然后说师傅，我错了，我没体会你的良苦用心。原来一朝一试都在生活之中，对吧？然后师傅说嗯，然后就走了。
这是他妈。
戏里面的情节，现实怎么可能呢？对吧？你挑三点水就就学会功夫了吗？
我跟你说，师傅为什么这么教你啊？
他也是这么被虐待过来的，他也他也不一定会，你知道吗？他师傅他打架他不一定能打咱们这网上看的还少呢，对吧？传统武术那咱就不说这个了啊。
那个速成的是什么？就你从少林寺下来了，哎，一肚子窝窝挺窝火，啥也没学会呀，走到路边看哎。
武术培训班对吧？就进去了。进去之后，我说师傅，我想学功夫，这里特别痛快，说那儿交钱。
交上钱之后呢，他会告诉你，20天后你就可以上那一台。
他说那来我怎么学呢？他说那。
功夫无非就是拳脚对吧？有规律的呀，一拳一脚嘛。
对方要是出拳。
你就蹲下掏当。
对方如果踢腿。
你就跳起来扫眼。
就让你背这个规律，背背下来之后呢，就是可以上擂台了。
你说行吗？
偶尔啊也能扫到那么一下，我觉得但是扫完之后，对方轻饶不了你，绝对照死揍你，对吧？
所以这呃这这两种流派呢都有点走极端。好吧，那咱们咱们这课是什么派呢？咱们是实战派。
实战派啊。
你得真的会打才行呀。
对吧因为你学功夫最后还是得能打呀。
下了场以后，没有人惯着你。
会就是会不会就是不会，咱们也不去搞学院，也不去搞速成，最后你得会写剧本才行。好吧，我为什么敢说？
咱们是实战派的。首先我在一线工作了十几年。
我有实战的经验。
然后呢，我这些年也带了很多学徒。
教了一些新人，我也经常给他们上课，所以我也懂一些理论。
系统的我也可以给大家讲。所以咱这个实战课里面。
用到学院派的理论和基本功的，咱也扎扎实实的去学。
然后用到一些真正的技巧性的东西，规律性的东西。
甚至有些地方真的可以走捷径的，咱也走。
对吧咱也把那些实战经验放进来。
所以说。
趁这个机会。
趁这次有这个完整的时间，因为这个肺炎这个疫情现在停工停产，剧组也开不了机。
他们呢就系统的把我这些年的呃所学所想总结成一套实战编剧课程。
有兴趣的同学。
一起学习，一起讨论一下，好不好？
这些年啊，我一直特别鼓励年轻人。
学习编剧，从事编剧。
为什么？
第一，从市场的角度来说啊，首先这个行业这几年一直在增长。
市场容量在不断的扩大，但是技术性的岗位一直跟不上。
就编剧啊这种创造性的岗位，尤其缺演员不缺明星一抓一大把，那个你不用惦记是吧？技术性的岗位非常缺。所以你如果现在的学习这个技能呢，在未来几年里面是很有机会的。
从市场的角度来讲，他有机会。好吧，成为编剧。还有一些人说我不想成为职业的编剧。
那么我觉得你学一下写作，学一下创作，也可以成为一个很好的副业。
现在你说。
这几年经济也不好，大家其实能体会到钱越来越难挣。有一个副业对你的生活来说是个双保险。
对不对？然后我这几年这个做编剧教学的过程中，很多爱好者也好，很多零基础的学员也好，他们经常会有几个顾虑。我也在这里跟大家说一下，好吧。第一个是关于他们经常会问一个问题，就是我不是科班的。
行不行？能不能到录音局？
这个我可以明确跟大家说啊，没问题的。
因为根据编剧行业的一个统计啊，现在的从业人员编剧里面。
科班出身呢只占40%，60%不是科班出身。
而且我不是说了吗？
他比你多挑了三年水，对吧？这个咱是可以弥补的不用担心这个问题。第二个还有一个常见的顾虑，就很多人会问一个文学功底的问题，这个问题问得非常好啊，就关于文学功底，很多人说哎我是理科生啊，我这个文学功底，我这差点意思能不能当编剧。
假设。
嗯，现在是晚上啊，假设你描写一下今天晚上这个外面的情况，你会说现在是春天嘛，你说外面乍暖还寒，然后嘞呃小风吹在脸上有一丝凉意。
然后今天晚上的月亮是什么样一个状态，衬托出一个什么样的意境，这就是你的文学功底。你描写的很生动。但是对于我们编剧来说就几个字，夜外最多再加一个冷，对吧？就夜景外景天气冷就明白就行了。
所以你说文学功底，你描述那么多呢，也没有什么用。
那你说台词，有些人说，那台词总需要文学功底了吧。
你如果写时装剧，那你的台词就是平常人说的话，你会说话，你就会写台词，你不需要去拽文，不需要去搞一些花里胡哨的对吧？你说我文学功力特别的差，那你别碰古装就完事儿了，我也不太写古装是吧？然后还有一个顾虑。
就是有些人会说那写剧本是不是需要创意，需要灵感呢？就是关于这个创意问题。
说我我我不我我没有创意怎么办？或者是我不知道我有没有创意。
这个我跟大家说一下啊。
创意人人都有。
只不过发现创意是需要训练的。
你不要说你没有创意，没有灵感。
我就问你，你会做梦吗？
你会做白日梦吗？
什么叫白日梦？你其实心里懂，就在那琢磨。哎呀。
如果有两个亿，我该怎么花呀？对吧？我先在北京买一套什么样的房？
然后我在上海再买一套什么样的别墅，然后我回老家再买一套什么？我跟你说，你安排的明明白白的。
这就是白日梦，这就是你的想象，这就是最初的灵感。梦是唯一的现实。
至于他。
怎么去加工，那就是后天训练的事情了。
好吧，因为每个人都会做这样的梦，你不用不好意思。
有的是关于金钱的。
你说啊那这个这个太俗了。
能不能呃行啊，这有什么用啊？西红市首富。
不就是这样的梦吗？
他不就是喜剧片吗？对吧？你幻想你有两个亿，这就是喜剧片，我告诉你对吧？还有说那还有的人幻想啊说哎呀，我当年要是跟那个谁在一块儿就好了。
我现在孩子都会打酱油，就在琢磨这个事儿，这不就是爱情片吗？
它就是爱情片的源泉。
对吧还有人会想啊说。
哎呀，特别是我们男的爱想说，哎，我当年如果坚持踢球，我现在说不定是个职业球员。
上一回世界杯，我就带领中国队，对吧？我就冲出去了励志题材嘛。
然后你们女生对应的这种梦可能就是个明星梦，对吧？我如果从艺我现在就是一个什么什么级别的腕儿，也是励志题材。然后到了这个腕儿之后，我就可以挣两个亿，然后又回到喜剧片，对吧？就是这种这其实这这些都是创意。所以我的意思就是你在创意方面。
不用去担心啊，人人都有。那你说人人都有，那人人都能当编剧啊，编剧就这么简单，没有人有天赋吗？天赋也有。
有些人确实天赋异禀，我跟你说什么样的人，他其实。
天赋异禀啊。
就你回想一下，以前我们读书的时候，一个班里。
谁只要一讲故事，一讲笑话，所有人都围上去。
对吧？然后很聚精会神的听下了课，他在走廊里说什么，所有人围了一圈，然后长大了以后吃饭的时候，然后谁一说话大家都听都想get就像等他的笑点。
这种人。
就是讲故事的天才。
嗯这种人在人群当中差不多占5%到10%吧。
人家这种人就是天才。
但是你不用去担心，你说你是不是天，你如果不是天，你不是天才，通过后天的训练也可以成为合格的编剧。但那种天才人家那是可遇不可求的呀。他们当然可以成为训练好了的话，可以成为牛逼的编剧。但是咱话说回来啊，人家干别的也能干的挺好，对吧？所以咱那个羡慕不来。
好吧，你就不用担心这个创意问题。
然后还有一些人有些年轻人有这样的顾虑，担心说编剧这个行业啊会不会很辛苦。
编辑这个行业天天熬夜，很焦虑，很辛苦，掉头发。
是吧。
这个呢。
我就不否认了，掉不掉头发了，你们自己看吧是吧？确实辛苦。
确实辛苦肯定辛苦，也会也会有点焦虑。
但是我告诉大家啊。
我。
恰恰是因为编剧辛苦。
而选择了做编剧。
因为我做这个行业。
我其实不是从编剧做起的，我做过所有的岗位，几乎我开始的时候做演员副导演。
就是选演员的那个副导演，就是最臭名昭著的那个角色那个岗位。
还做过现场制片，后来做执行制片人，然后做编剧、导演、制片人，我还自己投资过戏做出品人。
然后我还做个监制，啥叫监制呢？就是你又不用写，又不用拍，就监视一下就可以了，空一下场就能把钱挣了。这些岗位我都做过。
但是我最后为什么选择了做编剧？
就是因为编剧最辛苦。
能理解吗？很难理解是吧？
我告诉你们为什么。
因为你做任何行业，你都是想越做越往上走。
对不对？
然后呢，你越往上走，你就发现越越有很多牛逼的人。
牛逼的人呢。
我发现了一个规律，在我们这个行业。
特别牛逼的人，他不愿意做编剧。
就他特别有实力。
那他往往做制片人。
或者做出品人。
有些。
有还有点儿有点财的呢，他还能做导演。
有些甚至下场还可以当明星。
你要向上合作，往上走，跟这样的人合作抱大腿。
最好就是做编剧，因为做编剧他们才带上你。
因为他们不愿做这个新苦的岗位，明白我的意思了吗？
你想往上走，想抱大腿，你就得干脏活。
所以我兜兜转转一圈。我告诉你，我虽然从业这么多年，但我不是大腿。
我就是个手艺人。
所以我。
坚持做编局。